Okay,
so today we're going to talk about,
oh,
openness.
Now
you might say in some sense that
openness is the last discovered that the
big five traits,
and it's also the one I would say that
comes up most weekly in the factor
analysis.
When Hans ising formulated his trait
representation,
which was extroversion,
neuroticism and psychotic system.
He,
I felt that he encapsulated all of the
fundamental variation in human
personality and nick and he was loathed
to include intelligence as a personality
trait.
Now,
the relationship between psychologists,
ISM and openness is rather complex.
Isaac basically felt that people could
be extroverted and that would be the
positive dimension.
It could be,
you know,
high in negative emotion.
That'd be the negative emotion dimension
and that they also could have a
predisposition to psychosis and I guess
that would be.
He was thinking about the brain systems
that underlie schizophrenia and that
that tendency to dissociate and,
and develop hallucinations,
but also maybe the system in human
beings that are affected by
hallucinogenic drugs,
which seemed to affect human beings
differently than they have their other
creatures.
So.
But Isaac psychotic eventually was
broken down into low agreeableness and
low conscientiousness.
It didn't predict the predisposition to
psychosis at all and later factor
analysis found that you could load out
intelligence and creativity as a
personality dimension separately.
Now it's a bit tricky because you have
Iq measures and Iq measures are much
more direct measures of intelligence
than the personality measures.
I mean the personality measure is
something like,
do you think you're smart?
You know,
I mean I'm being a bit flip about that
because it's more sophisticated than
that,
but when you talk about someone as a
smart person,
you're generally referring to the trait
that we would describe as openness.
You also are doing that when you refer
to the to creativity as a,
as a previous position,
and you could measure the smart part a
lot better with ICU and ICU is also a
pretty good predictor of creativity so
well.
So let's see how they're associated.
So he remembered that you have your big
two traits.
Stability of plasticity and stability
breaks down into conscientiousness,
emotional stability and agreeableness,
and then you can see how each of the
aspects are correlated.
How highly they're correlated,
so industriousness and orderliness at
about point for volatility,
withdrawal and emotional stability or
neuroticism.
Actually about point six and
agreeableness and politeness at about
point four,
and then the next trait is extroversion
and openness that makes plasticity and
people who were high in plasticity tend
to be good entrepreneurs by the way,
and extroversion rates into
assertiveness and enthusiasm correlated
at about point five and then openness
and intelligence.
And the correlation there is lower.
It's point three,
five.
The average correlation between the big
five is point two and the correlation
between the big two is about point two.
And so you have to remember,
you might ask yourself,
well,
is a correlation of point for twice as
large as a correlation of point to
announce to that is no,
because you have to square them to
compare them arithmetically.
So a correlation of point to point,
oh,
four,
four percent squared,
right?
And a correlation port for gives you 16
percent squared.
So there's actually a difference of a
factor of four.
And so you need to remember that when
you're considering effect sizes so that
you can understand exactly what they
mean.
Now you know,
if you're accounting for 16 percent of
the variance,
which would be a correlation of point
four,
then that leaves 84 percent left
unexplained.
But that's a bit of an overstatement
most of the time in psychology because
our measures are are rather imperfect.
And so for example,
if you give someone a personality test
and let's say that the validity of their
self report is about point six,
three point seven,
which is probably what it is,
maybe it might be a little bit higher
than that.
So that's,
that means that they're self reporting
is only picking up 50 percent of the
variation in their personality.
And if you pick up,
you know,
if,
if your are,
if an are derived from that measure
accounts for 16 percent of the variance
in some sense it's twice as powerful as
it appears to be because the measure is
so error ridden.
And a lot of the things that we measure
in psychology are error written.
And what that means is that the
correlations are generally what it
means,
although not in variable isn't the
correlations are bigger than they look.
In any case,
the correlations that come up in
personality research are certainly big
enough to be meaningful.
And I would say meaningful in terms of
predicting major life outcomes and
predicting important economic outcomes
and that sort of thing.
So,
all right,
so one of the things you might ask
yourself is exactly what does
intelligence measure.
So we'll start with intelligence from,
from the and that would be equivalent to
intellect,
ruffin speaking.
So intellect in the big five,
the aspect seems to be associated with
interest in ideas.
Whereas the openness proper aspect seems
to be associated with aesthetic
sensibility and creativity.
That's the best way to think about as
far as we've been able to figure out.
And the biggest relationship is between
into intellect and intelligence as
measured psychometrically.
Now intelligence is an interesting
concept.
It's very controversial.
In fact,
if you.
One of the things that continually
happens over and over again in
psychology is that psychologists
discover all sorts of new kinds of
intelligence.
And you know,
the biggest two proponents of that sort
of thing,
I suppose we're Bob Sternberg who came
up with this thing he called practical
intelligence and then Howard Gardner who
came up with the theory of multiple
intelligences which had a very large
effect on educational psychology,
um,
when the theory was first proposed.
And that's not saying much because
generally speaking,
it's very difficult to find a discipline
that's more susceptible to fads and
educational psychology.
And as far as I can tell,
generally speaking,
each fat is worse than the previous one.
So no gardener positive that I think
there were seven.
Oh,
there they are,
seven or eight different intelligences,
linguistic,
musical,
logical,
mathematical,
spacial body,
kinesthetic,
interpersonal and interpersonal.
And people talk about emotional
intelligence and they talk about
practical intelligence.
And as far as I'm concerned,
all of that's complete rubbish.
And there's technical reasons for that.
I mean there's technical and
philosophical reasons for that.
The first thing is you can't just mess
up a word,
you know the whole point of having a
word is so that it defined some things
that described some things and doesn't
describe other things.
Right,
and so you can.
You can make the word intelligence
account for whatever you want so you can
say that the ability to dance as a form
of intelligence,
but the problem with that is you blur
out the word so badly.
You can't tell what it means anymore,
and so,
and I would also point out we had
perfectly good words for those major
intelligence as we called them talents
and so it's perfectly reasonable to make
a distinction between the talent and
intelligence.
Now you might say,
well,
how the hell do you know the difference?
Like if if things look similar to some
degree,
then how do you know if they're the same
or different?
Well,
that's exactly what you do when you do
the construct validity process.
So let's say you rated a number of
people on their dancing ability and then
you rated a number of people on their
ability to multiply two digit,
two digit numbers in their head quickly
while then you see technically if both
of those were intelligences than the
people who could dance better could
multiply two digit numbers faster in
their head and they would be slightly.
Sorry.
See that's what happens when I don't
have any diet coke.
So anyways,
if intelligence was the right word to
subsume both of those,
then what you see is that would be a
high correlation with people who are
good dancers would also be the ones who
could multiply most rapidly and I mean
multiply in their head but that.
But you're not going to be able to
extract out a single factor like that.
It's just not.
It's just not the case that those things
associate like that.
So for something to be one phenomena,
the things that it.
Hmm,
obviously I've talked too much this
semester.
All the things that are subsumed under
that definition have to be correlated
and highly correlated because otherwise
they're not the same thing.
It's the definition of the same thing.
Now,
Iq is a very peculiar construct,
a very unique construct from a
psychological perspective,
but also more generally from a social
science perspective because Iq has the
most predictive validity of anything
ever discovered in the social sciences
period.
Now another thing that is interesting
about Iq is that a lot of the people who
were interested early in the measurement
of intelligence were engineers,
turned psychologists and the engineers
have actually had quite a whopping
effect on psychology.
Part of the reason that psychology has
an advanced methodology and advanced
statistical techniques is because we got
invaded by engineers in the early part
of the 20th century,
and so the engineer has made our
measurements much more rigorous than
they would have otherwise been.
And it's been a huge advantage.
I mean,
one of the things that's happening to
psychology is it starting to eat other
disciplines,
so it's had a massive effect on
economics and it's going to have a
massive effect on political science.
And the reason for that is because we
know how to measure things and it
actually turns out to matter that you
know how to measure things.
Obviously.
I mean if you're going to be talking
about something that's specific and well
defined,
first of all,
if you can't make it specific and
well-defined,
all you can really do is argue about it
and you know there are better and worse
arguments.
But the problem is,
is that just because of an argument is
good,
doesn't mean it's right.
And that's a big problem.
It's also something to remember when
you're arguing about people that you
have a relationship with because you
know,
if you happen to be better at
structuring your arguments and your more
verbally fluent man,
perhaps more assertive and maybe less
agreeable,
you're going to win the arguments.
But that doesn't mean you're right.
It's unfortunately,
it's not that simple.
And so as far as I can tell me,
empirical process is the only way of
getting rid of the is restricting or
eliminating the catastrophic,
the detrimental effects,
pure theory
now and
well.
And our measurement techniques had been
pretty good about that.
Okay.
So now what happens with ICU here,
I can define Iq for you,
just so you know what it is.
So imagine that you had a library of
questions.
So here's some questions.
So there's millions of questions in this
data bank.
What's two times 68?
What's the capital of Georgia?
What's the definition of hypertrichosis
anemia?
What comes after in this sequence?
Two,
four,
eight,
16.
Remember these numbers?
So I'd tell you the numbers and then
you'd have to tell me that back to four.
One,
three,
five,
seven,
six slash 12 slash 15 slash 14.
18,
20,
22.
And then I might ask you in fact to
remember them backwards.
And that's a working memory task.
So,
okay.
So those are all questions that require.
They require abstraction and mental
operations.
That's,
that's the key as far as I can tell.
So you might say,
well exactly what constitutes an
abstraction.
And it looks to me like what an
abstraction is.
There's the capacity to formulate it and
abstraction.
There's the capacity to manipulate them
to formulate an abstraction.
I think what you do is you take a
phenomena and you represent it with
something that's low resolution,
that's more or less what an abstraction
is.
So for example,
if I imagined this classroom later,
um,
my,
my imagine grip presentation is going to
be a much lower resolution than the
actual classroom,
but it's sufficient for certain
purposes,
just like a thumbnail on a computer is
sufficient for certain purposes.
And then once I simplified the,
the,
the phenomena in question,
then I can also perform certain
operations on it,
say in imagination or semantically,
and the capacity to generate that
abstraction and the Trans Admin,
the ability to manipulate those seems to
be the core element of intelligence.
And I think part of the reason why
intelligence,
roughly speaking as a human dimension,
although you know,
obviously you can,
you can,
you can to some degree rank order
animals in terms of their capacity to
learn.
But there's this whopping
differentiation between human beings and
animals in this area particularly is
because we can use abstractions.
Now,
I heard a woman named Temple grandin
speak once and it was very interesting
talk.
She's very autistic and uh,
but very,
very,
very brilliant,
which is not very common for people who
are autistic.
Usually it's associated with a
substantial amount of intellectual
impairment,
but she also had an extraordinarily
devoted parent who spent almost all of
her time trying to pull her daughter out
of her autistic isolation.
Now grandon has gone on to become the
University of Chicago professor and she
works in,
in the agricultural area,
and she has redesigned the miss,
the shoots,
the walkways basically that take cattle
to the slaughterhouse and she's done
that to make them less,
much less stressful for the animals.
And part of the reason that she can do
that as far as she's concerned is
because she thinks like an animal.
And what that means as far as she can
tell is that she cannot generate an
abstraction.
Not Easily.
Now she can speak.
So obviously she learned to do it to
some degree,
but she talked more about inner talk,
more about deficits in imagination or
concretization of imagination.
So one of the weird things that you see
with autistic kids,
not frequently,
but now.
And then there's actually a famous
example of this on the web,
there's a guy,
I think he's from Britain and you can
take them in a helicopter and fly over a
city and then he can stand in front of a
piece of paper like 12 by eight,
start anywhere and draw the entire city,
you know,
and now and then you see autistic savant
who were children who can draw perfectly
realistically.
And so maybe they'll draw a horse and
they don't even start the horse.
Like a kid would,
like a normal kid would,
would sketch the outline of the horse
and put some eyes in,
you know,
they start anywhere and make the horse
perfectly detailed.
And what he claimed was that.
So she said,
okay,
you think of,
think of house or think of church.
And she says,
what comes to mind if you think of
church?
And maybe she'd say,
well you get this little image of
something that sort of shaped like this
with a steeple on top or a cross or
something like that.
And that's the church.
And so maybe you think of house and it's
like little kids house,
you know what's going to.
It's got a rectangle and a parallel and
Graham that's not a Parallelogram,
whatever the hell you called up things
on the top and then it's got a chimney
with smoke coming out of it,
right?
Two windows and the door house.
Yeah.
But there,
there are no houses like that.
Like each individual house looks a lot
different than that.
And so in order to have that conception
of house,
what essentially what you have to do is
you have to take the class of all
possible houses and extract out the
features that are in common across all
of them.
And that's an abstraction.
And so as far as brandon is concerned,
she doesn't have abstractions like that,
which when you asked her to remember to
think of church,
she remembers at Church it's always
singular instances.
Now the thing about human beings is
that,
you know,
we perceive singular instances to some
degree,
although I think our abstraction
capacity all often interferes with our
ability to do that.
But we also perceive abstractions,
and you can kind of tell this,
if you're ever trying to learn to draw,
like if I say draw a hand,
you guys,
most of you,
unless you have artistic training,
you're going to drop what's essentially
a hero,
Pacific hand.
And I,
I think the drawings,
the children come up with art drawings.
I think their hero glyphs,
they're abstracted representations that
are quasi linguistic.
They're not artwork there pro the
language,
right?
And so,
and here are glyphs,
of course,
we're one of the earliest forms of
written language.
It makes sense because if you want to
communicate about something,
why not draw an image,
you know?
And then eventually the image turns into
a word.
But I actually think that's the thing,
that's the developmental progression of
language among human beings.
It's the abstract image first,
and then it's the word.
Um,
anyways,
you know,
if you drew a hand,
you'd like to draw hero glyphic hand
five fingers or maybe even four,
right?
Because that's what they do.
That's what animators do.
You can't fit all those sausages on one
circle,
you know,
so they just simplify it down to four.
No one even cares.
You Watch an animation animated program,
which is highly abstracted,
right?
I mean homer Simpson,
it looks nothing like an actual person,
like really tremendously.
Unlike an actual person that's
completely irrelevant,
you know,
after two or three seconds,
it doesn't matter at all.
Which is also why I think three d movies
never really.
It's never a technology that's ever
caught on.
It's after the first four seconds.
Who the hell cares?
It's irrelevant whether you see it in
three dimensions because you don't need
much information to actually structure
your perception.
Now,
if you want to see your hand weirdly
enough so that you can draw it,
you have to snap out of your normal mode
of perception.
I find it's often a lot easier to do
that with one eye closed,
his flattens it out,
and then you have to stop looking at
your hand as if it's a hand.
You have to look at it again like it's
an object and as soon as you do that,
it's actually rather shocking because
it's such a strange looking thing.
Like if you.
If you put your hand in a non canonical
position,
that's a canonical position.
I would say you put your hand in the non
canonical position and then look at it.
It's,
it's the weirdest shape thing.
It's quite shocking to see it and then
you can draw it once.
You can actually see it like that,
but before that you're pretty much stuck
in hand.
So.
So anyways,
I think what happens with intelligence
is that people are capable of
abstracting and then they can manipulate
abstractions and so let's take another
look at what abstractions might be.
So now part of the reason I think that
abstraction is so useful is because
things are really,
really complicated and it's going to be
a lot more difficult to manipulate the
actual thing that to manipulate some
represent to the abstraction of it.
So if you could get an abstraction that
that captures the gist of the entity.
Now how will we do that is not exactly
obvious,
but if you can then you can expend a lot
more resources concentrating on the
relevant parts of the,
of the entity,
and a lot less time concentrating on the
irrelevant parts.
So you know,
so for example,
if you ask a child to draw a house,
what color the house is is irrelevant.
Now,
why it's irrelevant.
It's not exactly obvious.
I guess it's because color can vary
across houses and color varies across
all sorts of other things and so color
it turns out to be a non canonical
element of house so you can just
dispense with it.
When you're thinking about a house,
you'd say,
well it doesn't matter what color the
house is,
it's still a house.
So what exactly defines those features
that make something a house rather than
something else or are not that easy to
figure out.
You know,
you could say,
well how's has four walls and a roof and
those are the external walls.
And I guess you could identify the
minimal necessary components,
but even that's not so,
so simple.
And you could say a house is also
something that someone lives in which
allows you to put caves as houses
because caves obviously share very
little in common with a standard house.
So my point is,
is that it's difficult exactly to figure
out what set of features we do use to
determine whether something is a member
of a class.
There's this guy named a Gig or answer
who's thought about this a lot and he
thinks that we,
that there are a combination of
objective and functional basically.
And that enables us to do things like
come up with the category of things you
would take from your apartment if it was
on fire was a really interesting
category,
right?
Because most of the things that you're
going to take bear very little
resemblance.
It's hard to see why they make a
category.
Pat's family members probably in that
order.
Um,
photo albums,
identification.
What else might you take if you were
your phone,
I suppose,
what else would you take out of an
apartment during a fire?
Well,
you guys would be out on the street
stark naked obviously.
So while you get the point is that you
know,
those things that are just mentioned
seem to share very little in terms of
objective features in common,
but there's some reason that they still
go here as a category.
All right?
So anyways,
why do you need to abstract?
Well,
because you can handle the complexity of
the world better.
Even your perception is a form of
abstraction,
you know,
because when you look at someone,
a lot of the abstraction has done for
you because you just can't perceive very
well.
But when you look at someone,
first of all,
you only see the surface of them that's
facing you and not the other surface.
So that's a big limitation.
You only see them now in this split
second rather than extended across time.
You don't see any of their
microstructure right beyond the,
beyond the general pattern of the
physiology at this level of resolution,
you don't see anything below that.
I can't see yourselves or your organs or
anything like that,
which is actually a real problem often
for us and I can't see the systems that
you're part of.
So right off the bat,
just to perceive,
gives you a low resolution
representation and that lot of that's
limitations of your process and your
eyes just can't zoom in that far.
You don't have the cortical capacity to
improve your vision,
you know,
plus how much do you really want to see
it one time,
no more than necessary,
whatever that means.
And evolution seems to take care of that
problem.
So your perception abstracts for you
right away,
but then I would say maybe you make a
leap from perception to conception or
something like that.
And so that would be the leap from the
perception of the actual object to the
image of the object.
And then elite from the image of the
object to the word.
So it looks to me like a word is a
representation of an image which is a
representation of a,
an an object or situation.
It's something like that.
So,
and you need those because you have to
deal with the complex world.
So here's,
here's one way of thinking about it.
So look at the top left corner of that
diagram.
So I called that the thing in itself and
what it is is it's an array of dots
roughly speaking and I think there's 360
dots there and you might say,
well,
and then if it was a real world object
you could imagine that would be in three
dimensions not to because that's too,
and it would be transforming because it
would be also extended across time.
So and it would have micro structures
that were far smaller than that and
macro structures that were far bigger,
but so even that is an abstraction,
but it's,
I'm,
I'm using a fairly complex abstraction
to rip represent the thing in itself.
That's the thing you cannot perceive,
right?
What something actually is you just get
an image and then the next five things
are ways you could look at that.
So you could say,
well it's a rectangle.
You could say it's four rectangles.
And forget about the dots.
You could say that it's,
I think that 16 lines or what is it?
30 two lines,
a 24 lines.
So if you were going to,
if that thing in itself was an orchard
and you are going to walk north,
south to north through it,
that would be a good representation.
You know,
those would be corridors roughly
speaking and then object for is a
combination of object one and object to
and then object five is well all of it's
blurred out or the little groups of six
dogs and so you might say,
well what is that thing?
And then the answer is well it's any of
those five things.
And so that's an interesting way of
thinking about it too because one of the
things that shows you is that you can
disagree about what something is right
at the level of perception and then you
might say,
well which of those is the best
representation?
And the first answer might be,
well the most complex one,
the top one on the left hand corner,
but that's not necessarily the case.
It might depend on what you want the
representation for like imagine.
It's weird.
It's weird because imagine you have a
map.
Okay.
And so you think,
well,
I'm going to make the best map in the
world and so you make a map that's
exactly the same size as the territory
that it represents and has all the
detail.
Well that's not any use at all that
thing because you could just use the
territory,
right?
So you know the,
just because as a map gets increasingly
detailed to some degree,
it's increasingly useless as a map.
And so what you need is this weird
combination between accuracy and
simplicity.
And so you want your map to be no more
complicated than is necessary to take
you from point a to point b.
that's it.
So because otherwise it wouldn't be
simple to use and the additional
complexity would eliminate the utility
of the,
of the map.
So,
so you might say that what we're trying
to do with our intelligence is to get
what we need with the least amount of
effort possible.
And,
and you know,
there's sort of a psg eddie and idea
that's lurking behind that,
which is,
well,
you know,
you have limited resources.
You don't want to expend any more energy
than is necessary.
And you want to build representations of
the world that suffice to keep you going
now and then next week and next month,
and then you know alone and then in
groups and so you build a representation
of the world that has some concordance
with the thing in itself,
but has this functional simplicity so
that you could actually use it in the
real world.
All right,
so back to this diagram.
So I've got the object and five
representations and then there are ways
of representing it linguistically at the
bottom.
So
what that is,
the words are basically a simplification
of something that's already simplified.
So,
okay,
so intelligence seems to have something
to do with the process of functional
simplification.
Now back to the library of questions.
So you have this database of questions
and so then what you do is pull out 100
questions randomly.
All right?
And you want to pick out 100?
Because if you just pick out one,
like if I asked you what the capital of
Georgia was and I asked you what the
capital of Georgia was and you got it
wrong and you got it right.
I couldn't really say with any degree of
certainty that that means that you have
more intelligence because the
probability that I get an accurate
measure with one question is quite low,
but if I use three questions while then
you know,
I would,
I would start to become.
My measurement would start to become
less error written and if I use 10,
it would even be better if I use 20.
For a personality questionnaire.
The rule of thumb,
and this is just a rule of thumb,
is that if you don't have 20 questions
in the questionnaire,
then you don't have enough questions to
really generate a reliable measure.
So you'll still.
You'll still see single item measures
used in psychology,
but you can add additional accuracy bike
by increasing the number of items.
I designed an Iq test a while back and
we got a pretty good.
We got pretty good reliability and
pretty good validity.
Reliability as you know,
you test the same set of people twice
and the rank order of their performance
stays the same.
So if you've got 90 on the previous
test,
you'd get 90 and if you've got 95
because you're more intelligent than
this example,
if you've got 95 in the last one,
you'd get 95 on this one.
So that's reliability.
You can get a pretty,
we could get it pretty reliable Iq test
with nine items,
but it was substantially improved with
17 and with increments,
you know,
you get a,
uh,
what do you call it?
Diminishing returns.
So a hundreds,
20,
okay,
so you pull out a 100 questions and then
you take 100 people and you give them
those questions and then you score them
right and wrong.
That's all there is.
And then you sum the scores.
Okay?
So basically that,
that the sun behaves like the average.
Let's say you average the scores just to
make the argument a little bit more
straightforward,
you average the scores and so each of
you gets the average of,
you know,
a calculated across the times that you
were right and wrong.
So it's an approximation of the
frequency of your,
of how right you were.
And then we rank order you one to 100.
That's Iq,
that's all there is to it.
So now people say Iq doesn't exist.
Well that's annoying because all they're
doing is gerrymandering.
The definition of the word exist,
you know,
because you can do that if you ask if a
is equivalent to be.
The answer is it depends on what you
mean by a and what you mean by being.
It's almost always a foolish question
because you can take b and a and bend
them and twist them in such a way that
you could make one thing and another
thing without too much problem.
People usually get around that by only
using a word in a context,
right?
In a sentence or a phrase or a paragraph
that defines the word so that you can't
weasel around like that.
But,
but more specifically in psychology,
we have methods to tell if something is
real,
you know,
and psych ad.
If Iq doesn't pass the test of reality
for a psychological measure,
then no other psychological measures
passed the tests because they're
validated exactly the same way I cue is.
And they don't work as well,
so you can say,
well no,
that's not real,
but then you have to throw out,
you probably have to throw out the
social sciences completely in so far as
they're actually sciences,
because the same statistics are used to
generate their findings.
So you can't just say,
well,
this really powerful thing doesn't
exist.
Well a bunch of these weak things exist
and they're measured the same way.
You don't get to play that game.
So.
Okay.
So does it exist?
Well,
you can measure it,
you can measure it reliably.
So that's definitely something you know,
because you might say,
well there's your shadow exists.
Well,
generally speaking,
under normal conditions,
you condition your shadow relatively
reliable,
you know,
does it exist?
Well it passes one test of existence.
You can't detect it with a number of
senses.
You can't touch it,
for example.
But you know,
whether or not something exists is
actually a rather tricky question,
but you can measure it and it's useful
and that's not a bad definition of,
of exist.
So what's it good for?
Well,
it predicts major life outcomes.
And importantly,
so,
and we,
we can talk about the power of
intelligence momentarily.
If you were actually going to calculate
an Iq score per se,
you would take the rank order that I
just described and you would correct it
for age because you know,
you can't really expect a seven year old
to know as much as a 15 year old or a 20
year old.
So generally speaking,
if you take a technical Iq test,
it will rank order you,
but it'll only rank order you with
people of the same age as you.
So that's just another,
you know,
it's an additional correction whether or
not that actually gives you a more
accurate estimate of Iq is depends on
what you mean by accurate.
A very bright seven year old generally
doesn't know enough to do much useful in
the way of work,
but they can learn extremely quickly.
And so,
um,
if you compared seven year olds to
people of other ages purely in terms of
their score on an Iq test,
there's a high probability that you
would underestimate their speed of
learning.
By the same token though,
by the time you're 40,
you have a lot of accumulated knowledge
and so if,
if you only measured learning speed than
you would underestimate,
you would overestimate that seven year
olds advantage over the 40 year old Iq
is basically a unitary phenomenon,
but you can fractionated into.
It's a very,
very complicated for reasons that I'll
tell you about in a minute.
If you had to divide Iq into two,
the way you would divide it would be
into crystallized and fluid intelligence
and fluid intelligence would be roughly
the ability to learn and crystallized.
Intelligence would be roughly a measure
of how much you've learned.
Now those are separate to some degree,
and here's why.
They're separate.
As you age,
your capacity to learn decreases.
It's quite ugly,
so by the time you were about 24,
you're starting to get stupider from the
perspective of being able to learn,
and that's just pretty much a linear
trip downhill until you depart the
world.
So it's,
it's,
it's nasty to see because it's quite a
steep degeneration.
You can stave that off by the way with
cardiovascular and cardiovascular
exercise and weightlifting,
so that's the best way to keep your
learning capacity attack.
It's not to do cognitive exercises,
instituting physical exercise,
and then as you age,
then the amount you know goes up and
what happens is those two things are
actually tend to average out.
So now you might say,
well,
if I'm claiming that Iq,
is this a unitary thing,
how can I make the claim that you can
divide it into two elements and that
those elements are in some sense
separate and I think the reason is for
this.
So your,
your prefrontal Cortex,
roughly speaking,
so that's the part of your brain here
forward.
You can think about in part,
it's the part that does the programming
of motor activity,
voluntary motor activity,
but it also seems to be so let's say
you're doing something new and you're
pretty clunky and awkward at it and then
you do it more and more and you get
smoother and smoother and smoother out
it.
And what you tell them,
what happens is you're using your
prefrontal cortex and to some degree
your whole right hemisphere when you're
first doing it,
and then as you get better and better at
it,
the ability shifts to the left and then
it goes backwards.
So what's happening to some degree is
your prefrontal cortex is programming
the rest of your brain and you could
think of fluid intelligence as a measure
of the ability of your,
of your brain to program itself and
crystallized ability as a measure of how
much programming is there and then so
they're separate in that manner because
they performed separate functions.
But then you can also understand that
the better your programmer is,
the better the programming is going to
be.
So that inflates the correlation.
And so you can have two separate things
functional functionally that are even
dissociable in terms of age,
but because they work so tightly
together,
it's like how fast can you dig a hole
and how big is the pile of dirt?
Well,
obviously those two things are different
in some important sense,
but they're going to be highly
correlated because the faster you can
take a whole,
the bigger the pile of dirt and so.
So anyways,
crystallized intelligence is often also
often measured as verbal intelligence,
but the better measure fundamentally is
crystallized intelligence.
Now you know how we looked at the I
personality hierarchy,
right?
That was this and what you see is three
strata roughly speaking aspect,
trait super factor,
and it looks like the super factors.
I would say the validity of those super
factors is not yet clear.
You can get a lot of useful prediction
by looking at the traits and there's
more and more evidence.
There's about 400 studies now using the
aspects.
There's more and more evidence that you
can also derive additional useful
predictive validity from differentiating
the,
the personality down to the,
you know,
to the,
to the aspect level.
So that's the highest resolution
personality model we have.
There are people who claim that there's
something at the apex which you might
call good personality,
but I don't think so.
I think it's.
I don't think so.
You'd have to read the literature to
understand the,
the dispute.
It's a statistical dispute roughly
speaking,
but um,
we've found in our research that
stability and plasticity early
correlated at point two,
they're pretty separate.
So I'm going to stick with that for now
even though it might be wrong.
What?
Okay.
So
can you explain this properly?
If you read the cognitive literature and
the neuropsychological literature,
you will find that neuro psychologists
tend to assume that there are forms of
cognitive ability that you cannot
describe as Iq and they make that claim
because they'll take a test and they'll,
they'll use the test to measure
something and then no correlate that
with Iq.
And the correlation will only be about
point two or point three.
And so they'll say,
well,
that's not a high enough correlation to
justify saying that those things are
identical because the correlation should
be more like point eight for them to be
identical.
But the problem is,
let's say I had a measure of your Iq,
your Iq and your Iq,
your Iq.
And then I asked you two questions and
you and you and you and I summed your
answers whether they were correct or
incorrect.
Now what would happen is there'd be some
correlation between your total score on
those two questions and your overall Iq.
Maybe it would be point three,
but that wouldn't justify me in planning
that the two question Iq test is
different than the full scale Iq test.
It's just worse
and you're going to run into this
problem when you read psychological
literature and if you ever do it,
do any research because it's very
difficult to determine whether you get
what's called discriminant validity,
which is this thing measures this,
this thing measures this thing and
they're actually different or whether
you just have a lousy measure of this
and allows you measure of this.
And so the correlation is low.
Now here's a neuropsychological test and
you could make the case that this is
measuring something different than Iq.
So imagine you see an array of 12
pictures.
They're just drawings,
drawings of a telephone and a boot and a
chair.
Just common objects.
Okay?
So you see 12 of them.
And then you have to click one and then
when you do that they move and then the
next time you have to click one,
you haven't already clicked and then
they move again and you click and they
move again and you click and you see by
the time you get to about eight of them,
you're starting to run into trouble
because it's difficult to remember more
than eight abstraction simultaneously.
Seven actually in some people claim it's
as low as four.
That's the capacity of working memory,
which is why we kind of like phone
numbers to be seven digits long.
A lot of the things we want to just
remember r s r seven,
you long.
And if we want to remember more than
that,
we chunk.
Although you know,
if I show you some dots,
okay,
say,
well how many dogs?
Three.
You don't have to count them.
You can see three dogs.
You can see for dogs,
it's not obvious that you can see five
dots at that point.
You start to go three and two.
And then if there are six dots,
well that's how they would be arranged
on a dice dice,
right?
The reason they'd be reached on the dice
that way is because you could see two
sets of three and for six,
you know,
if there are sort of randomly dispersed
like that,
I say,
well how many dots is that one?
You have character.
And what that shows you is that your
working memory,
which is really a function of fluid
intelligence,
is a very,
very narrow thing.
And it's like your vision.
You know,
remember we saw the gorilla video,
right?
Then you can only pick up the thing that
you're attending to.
Well,
working memories like that,
it's this narrow,
narrow form of attention and it,
it sort of specifies unitary phenomenon.
I mean that's not quite unitary,
but it's close enough.
And I think the reason that it does
that,
it's like why is your attention so
narrow is because often what you're
trying to do as you work in the world is
to make binary choices.
You know,
you don't want to choose between 20
things you want to read.
You want to choose between two things
because then when you choose between two
things,
you can actually act if it's still two
things can't act.
If it's one thing you could act.
So imagine you go into Chinese
restaurant is a good example because
Chinese restaurants virtually always
have like 400 items on the menu and you
might ask yourself,
well,
how the hell do you figure out what you
want and what you don't do is go through
every single menu item and,
and it because you'd be there for a
week.
So what you seem to do is eradicate
chunks.
So you might say,
well I'm not in the mood for anything
but fish.
Okay Bang.
Three quarters of the menu disappears,
you know?
And then you might go,
well I don't want it brandon whack.
And then another half is gone and now
you're down to maybe eight choices and
you know,
you reduce that to four and then two to
perhaps,
well I'd like this or I'd like that.
But the waiter doesn't care about that.
The waiter wants to know which one you
want because until it's reduced to one,
you don't get to act.
And so the reduction,
the reduced narrow strip that we use to
perceive the world and partly is a
consequence of processing inadequacy,
but it's also partly because we really
are trying to reduce things all the time
to zero in one,
right?
Yes or no.
So okay,
so back to the this three stratum theory
of cognitive abilities.
Now you've got this array of 12 items
and it keeps shifting and then what I
could do is score you by the number of
duplications you if you pick the same
mind that more than once you lose a
point.
So the maximum points you can get is 12.
And you know,
people usually make three or four
mistakes.
And so I could take your score on that
test.
Maybe I'd give it to you two or three
times just to make sure I have a
reasonably stable indicator and then I
can correlate it with your full scale
fluid Iq.
And I get a correlation of about point
two,
five or point three.
Now,
if you don't know anything about
psychometrics,
you'd say,
Oh,
well that's obviously measuring
something different than full scale Iq
because it only correlates at point two,
five or point three,
but what it turns out is no,
it's more analogous to the problem that
we were just talking about where I asked
you three questions and tried to derive
your entire icu from that.
It's just a bad measurement.
Now what happens is if you take the
neuropsychological tests that people
have developed that theoretically assess
the function of different parts of the
brain,
so and you factor in analyze them and
you extract out a single factor,
the single factor,
it looks exactly like fluid
intelligence.
Now,
is it exactly the same as fluid
intelligence?
It would be the onus would be on the
person who claims it's not to
demonstrate the difference.
We did give university students have a
very extensive battery of prefrontal
cortical tests and measured their Iq and
then we used the prefrontal cortical
test average and the ICU to predict
grades and what we did find was the
prefrontal tests predicted over and
above the eye Iq,
but we thought maybe if you don't,
the prefrontal average and the ICU and
you added them to to predict grade,
say that's a regression analysis.
They both added in so they predict.
They predicted different parts of the
variation.
It added additional you necessarily
information.
However,
if you took all the neuropsychological
tests and all the individual Iq tests
and you put them in one data set and
then extracted out a single factor is
that would be fluid intelligence roughly
speaking.
That predicted grades very well,
and then what was leftover didn't
predict it all.
So what we concluded was that
neuropsychological tests,
prefrontal cortical tests,
test intelligence,
and they test a slightly different thing
than fluid intelligence tests do,
but that isn't because they're testing
something different.
It's because fluid intelligence tests
the way they're currently constituted
don't sample the universe of potential
questions as well as they should.
So it wasn't that we discovered
something different.
We discovered a measurement error
roughly speaking,
that only took five years.
By the way,
it took five years to figure that out.
It was very annoying because when we
started,
I was trying to predict grades,
you know,
and I didn't know the ICU literature
very well at that point because
psychologist don't usually teach it very
much because Iq bothers the hell out of
everybody and so and the neuro
psychologists who have their own field
are,
you know,
they're motivated to make the claim that
they've discovered something new and I
just took that on face value.
But then we tried to predict like,
okay,
if I'm going to predict how well you do
at your job while I want to get a good
cognitive measure,
because if it's a complex job,
it keeps changing and you have to learn
to keep up and if you can't do that,
you're not going to do very well.
So that will be bad for you and it would
be bad for everyone around you.
And so we were trying to pick up
additional information that would enable
that,
the accuracy of that prediction to be
increased and looked at the neuro psych
literature.
But at most it was an ambivalent
success.
Okay.
So how does that relate to this?
Well,
at the bottom tier where it's the most
differentiated,
you have single tests and there are only
correlated with each other at about
point to maybe point three.
So you might say,
well they're all measuring different
things.
They're not,
they're all measuring the same thing
badly.
And then you might clump them.
So let's say I asked you,
Oh God,
maybe I give you a test that asks you
tested your vocabulary with six letter
words and then I gave you another test
that tested you vocabulary with seven
letter words and another one that tested
your vocabulary with eight letter words.
And I said,
well,
those are all different tests.
While they would correlate quite highly,
not perfectly,
but I can clump them together and make
one sort of super test out at them.
And then I could take super test a and
super testy and super test B C and look
at the correlations between those and
those would climb to about point five or
point six.
And then if I clump the super tests
together,
which would be happening by the time we
got to stratum to there,
then the correlation between the tests
would start to rise to the bug point
seven.
And then if I collapsed all the super
tests into a single measure,
then the correlation between any of
those stratum to tests and g because
that would be the highest level thing.
G is general intelligence.
That's roughly speaking.
Fluid intelligence.
The correlation between any of the super
tests and g would be about point eight.
So the point of all this,
there's no way of discussing this sort
of thing without doing it statistically
and technically because are statistical
and technical processes.
So what happens is,
is that now let's say now you have a
measure of fluid intelligence.
Okay,
you've got this measure and you take one
of the stratum two sets of tests and you
use both to predict academic
achievement.
What happens is that the super factor g
kills the rest of them.
You're just not going to be able to find
any of the tests in the bottom strata
that are going to add to the prediction
of what the general factor can give you.
Now with with with personality,
that's just not the case.
You can't pull out a single factor that
predicts how personality is going to
influence jobs.
You know,
performance across your life.
If you add neuroticism,
if you take the single factor and you
add neuroticism,
neuroticism is going to kick the single
factor out.
Conscientiousness is gonna,
kick the single factor out and so forth
because there isn't a single factor.
It's not.
The tests aren't highly correlated
enough to say that they're all measuring
the same thing to some degree.
The personality traits really are
different.
You know you can clump them into
plasticity,
instability,
but even there,
your loot you,
you're maintaining a lot of validity.
So if I took stability and then he used
conscientiousness to predict job
performance,
conscientiousness would white boats
stability,
it'd be a better measure,
but you never get that.
You virtually never get that with the
lower tests in the ICU straddle.
Okay,
now,
yeah.
Well I just talked to you about that.
So that's,
that's a.
that's a good representation of how
these things are associated.
So at the bottom you have the single
tasks and then they chunk into say
sequential reasoning,
quantitative reasoning and induction on
the fluid intelligence size side and
general knowledge and language
development.
On the crystallized intelligence side,
that's the red.
And then they're all subsumed underneath
fluid intelligence,
which is the measure that you really
want to have.
Okay?
So what good is that?
Well,
it basically correlates point five with
major life outcomes and that's 25
percent of the variance and maybe you
can get into a bit higher than that,
but it will just stick with point five
as a,
as a representation.
And so let's say,
let's say you take a bunch of students,
100 of them,
and you want to sort them into those who
will pass a class with a 50 percent
failure rate.
Okay?
So you just pick them randomly.
You're going to pass,
you're going to fail,
you're going to pass,
you're gonna fail.
So that's no knowledge.
I have no predictive dominance
whatsoever,
so my validity,
the validity of my classification is
basically going to be equivalent chat,
zero,
right?
I'm only going to have a 50 percent
chance of picking who passes and who
fails.
If I used Iq,
if I had all your Iq scores and I did
the prediction,
I get right 75 percent of the time,
so it's a huge difference.
It cuts the failure rate in half by
using ICU and ICU is a very good
predictor of health and it's a predictor
of longevity.
It's a predictor of resistance to
posttraumatic stress disorder.
It's a predictor of obviously
occupational status.
It's a predictor of educational success.
It's a predictor of income,
it's very powerful predictor,
and here's another way of
conceptualizing its effect.
So imagine that you could choose how you
were going to be when you were born,
and this is in North America because
it's gonna vary by society at least to
some degree.
You get to be born into a family that's
at the 95th percentile for wealth,
or you get to be born at the 95th
percentile for intelligence who's better
off at the age of 40.
And the answer is the person who picks
being born with an Iq in the 95th
percentile at birth,
it's more powerful predictor of longterm
life outcome.
Then familial wealth.
So,
and it shows up everywhere.
Like one of the things we did recently
was looking at disgust sensitivity.
We're going to talk a little bit about
that when we talk about
conscientiousness because orderly people
seem to be more sensitive to discuss the
disorderly people.
That seems to be why they're ordering.
But the higher you are in Icu,
the less disgust sensitive you are.
Now,
we don't know exactly why that is.
Maybe it's because,
you know,
maybe you could make the inference that
Iq is,
is in related in some way to the
physiological integrity of the Cortex,
you know,
rather than the limbic system,
which is the source of say,
emotions and motivations.
Um,
and the more powerful it is,
the more inhibitory capacity it has over
the more fundamental motivations and
emotions you could make that case.
The problem is,
is that intelligent people don't
necessarily seem to be any less
impulsive,
so,
and you can have a pretty vicious
personality disorder that's
characterized by extremely disorganized
behavior and a complete inability to put
longterm plans into operation and still
have a high Iq.
So what are the things we really can't
figure out?
It's just a hell of a thing to try to
figure out is like the relationship
between Iq and industriousness is zero
and that just makes no sense to me
because most of the brain models are
predicated on the idea that your ability
to engage in longterm planning is the
factor that's associated with
intelligence.
But then industrious people seem to not
only engage in longterm planning,
they seem to do it right so that if
there are more industrious,
they put their plans into operation then
the plans that actually work,
but it's not correlated with Iq.
So then I can't figure out,
well obviously the industrious person in
some ways able to regulate their own
behavior.
They're not procrastinating,
for example.
And you'd think that that the ability to
not procrastinate would be a cognitive
feature,
but it doesn't seem to be and we have no
idea what makes people industrious and
we can't figure it out.
So it's this incredibly potent
predictor.
It's just about as powerful as ICU and
we have no idea what it is.
So.
So if you think,
if you have a smart idea about that and
you want to pursue it,
like feel free because there's a big
mystery there that no one's been able to
crack and we'd been added for a long
time and have had almost no success.
You know,
we had people do things like give them
sentences of ends,
ams and use sort of randomly distributed
and then we'd have them count the use,
you know,
like a whole page of sentences.
They're not census or just strings of
letter county use.
How useless,
you know,
you'd think that someone industrious
would do that better.
It's like they don't.
That's an Iq test that people who can
count the use faster have hierarchies,
almost everything that you would do that
would where it has to do with
manipulation of abstractions of any
sort.
Even something that basic seems to be
fundamentally associated with Iq.
People with higher iqs have slightly
bigger heads.
If you control for body size,
they have slightly bigger brains.
the axons on their neurons are a bit
thicker so that the electrical messages
seem to travel a little bit more
efficiency efficiently.
They are slightly faster in simple
reflex test,
so it goes right down to the level of.
Because they're simple reflex light goes
on pushing buttons.
There's not many neurons mediating that
response,
you know,
chains of neurons.
There's only a few neurons communicating
so that you can do that,
but even at that relatively simple
processing level,
Iq is associated with speed,
so there's a physiological component.
You're less likely to develop
Alzheimer's disease if you have a high
Iq,
and maybe that's because your brain is
just more robust,
you know,
so you could sustain damage,
say up to 50 percent of your brain,
you wouldn't even show it if you're,
if you have a sufficiently high Iq.
Whereas if you're,
you know,
if you're on the bottom end of the ICU
distribution,
you're much more,
you seem to be much more susceptible to
physiological damage.
Um,
nutrition is a big predictor of Iq
variation.
So,
and a lot of that's been hammered out of
modern,
you know,
so 150 years ago,
people's Iq was pretty tightly
associated with their nutritional
status,
but now,
you know,
they're very few people in North America
who don't have enough to eat even though
there's some variation in quality of
diet and that's flattened out a lot of
the,
uh,
cultural variability and intelligence.
Okay.
So this is a,
um,
this guy named Hemphill,
did this paper read American
psychologist a while back,
and one of the things he was interested
in doing,
remember we talked about effect sizes,
right?
How big is an effect in psychology or
the social sciences in general?
And people have used rules of thumb that
point five was a moderate effect and
point three was a,
you know,
a minimal effect.
And point two was,
uh,
you know,
starting to diminish to the point of non
utility,
but what handheld did instead of
guessing because that was just a guess
was actually go and look at papers that
were published in psychology to see what
effect sizes are being reported.
So it's an empirical analysis of how big
the effects that psychologists and other
social scientists report.
And so what he found was that,
um,
the highest third of papers.
So the,
the third of papers that had the biggest
effects reported effects from point
three.
Five,
two point seven,
eight.
I'm the middle third from point two,
one point three,
three,
and the lower third from point.
Oh,
to two point two.
One.
So is there another?
Yeah.
If you look on the left side here,
you see that and are lasted point one
five,
characterize as the first quarter of
published studies and R of point one,
five,
two point three,
the next core tile,
so 50 percent of psychological studies
report and are of less than point three,
five 90 percent report and are of less
than point five and only 78 percent
reported our point five or above.
So what that means is that the
relationship between Iq and say academic
performance or longterm life income is
higher than that reported in all but
about five percent of psychology
studies.
Okay.
So here's an interesting.
You might say,
again,
in order to determine whether something
exists,
you have to be able to measure it and
then it has to be good for something.
So it has to be grippable and has to be
usable as a tool will save for,
for the sake of argument,
what sort of Iq do you need for what
kind of job?
Um,
this was derived from a company called
wonderlic and wonderlic does employment
testing.
Psychologists usually don't use the
wonderlic test.
It's a relatively short Iq test and it's
a good test,
I think don't use it because it was
developed commercially,
but we tested the wonderlic out a lot
and it has excellent psychometric
properties.
It's a very good Iq testing.
Probably airs a little bit in testing
crystallized Iq rather than fluid Iq,
but we won't argue about that for the
time being.
All right,
so if you have an Iq from 130,
116 to 130,
that puts you in the [inaudible] 86 to
95th percentile.
Right?
So that means you're minimally.
If there were eight people in a room on
average,
you'd be the smartest person.
Okay.
I should tell you,
just so you know that
if you're a state college students,
we use the US as an example because
there's more differentiation between the
American universities in terms of
quality.
Then there is the Canadian universities,
if you're in a.
If you're in an average American
postsecondary institution,
your Iq is 115,
and so you know,
you think that's not all that bright,
but that's brighter than seven out of
eight people in the general population,
and so there are as many people.
If you look at the North American
distribution,
so we have the 50th percentile in the
middle of the normal distribution.
You have the 85th percentile here and
you have the 15th percentile here.
It's about 70 percent of people fall
between the 15th and the 85th percentile
or right at the 50th percentile.
You're not really very literate,
and so what that means is that in the
United States there's just as many
people who aren't literate as there are
people who are in college and what I
would mean by literate is not so much
like here's a bare bones definition of
literate.
You could follow written instructions
and so what that means is it's kind of a
twofold issue,
right?
You can,
you can make out the words and the
phrases and the sentences,
but then you can translate them into
actual action.
You can use them as information and an
85 you're going to have not a very good
time doing that,
and so when you're wondering things
about the way society is structured and
white people are not,
don't necessarily make the most
intellectually sophisticated choices.
One thing that's very much worth
remembering is that there's just as many
people who are functionally illiterate
in North America as there are people who
are in,
you know,
tier one colleges.
It's quite shocking.
Anyways.
Okay,
so you want to be an attorney,
a research analyst and editor and
advertising manager,
a chemist,
an engineer,
and executive assistance analyst and
auditor.
So you're up in the professional levels
there.
You need an ICU of at least 116 and so
130 would be better.
My suspicions are that the average Iq of
people in this room is about 1:20
to 1:25.
It might be a little higher than that.
It's hard to measure Iq in the ute
population because a lot of people have
English as a second language and so that
makes it harder to,
you know,
it's harder to measure crystallized
intelligence,
obviously using an English language
test,
but that's we found when we've done our
studies at the uft that the average
exceeds 1:20,
so you know,
so you guys have the cognitive power to
basically pursue professional level
careers,
um,
from 1:10
to 1:15
manager,
supervisor,
programmer,
teacher,
general manager,
purchasing agent,
registered nurse sales account
executive.
These are actually empirically derived
by the way.
So the wonderlic company has tested a
very large number of people.
And so these are the actual averages of
the professions that they are
describing.
It's not hypothetical
108 to 100,
three to 108.
So that's the 60 to the 70th percentile
clerk,
customer service Rep,
computer operator,
medical debt collector secretary,
accounting clerk,
general sales,
telephone sales assistant manager,
credit clerk,
drafter,
designer,
bookkeeper.
There's a lot of white color,
like low level entry level white collar
jobs in that particular category.
So that would be the brighter people
among the high school students who
didn't go to college.
And University Iq,
this is dead average 50th to the 55th
percentile.
Police officer,
receptionist,
cashier,
general clerical staff inside sales
clerk,
meter reader,
printer teller,
data entry,
electrical helper,
dispatcher,
and general office.
So that's right at 195 to 98.
So that's the 42nd to the 45th
percentile.
Quality Control Checker,
claims clerk,
security guard or unskilled labor.
So look,
the unskilled laborers are up at 95th to
98.
Right?
So that's,
you're still at the unskilled labor
level.
You're still have an Iq that's higher
than 40 percent of the population.
Arc Welder,
diasend or mechanic medical,
dental assistant Iq 87 to 93 messenger,
factory production worker Assembler,
food service worker,
nurses aid,
warehouseman,
custodian,
janitor,
material handler and packer.
Okay.
So now what you see happening,
the difference that it looks to me like
you can do job,
you can conceptualize jobs most simply
with a two by two matrix.
Okay.
So there's managerial,
administrative jobs and creative jobs.
That's the first one.
And then there's low complexity.
High complexity and so what you're
starting to fall into the 21st to the 30
percentile,
so that's still one person in three are
low complexity managerial jobs and so
what I mean by that is that if you're in
a low complexity job,
imagine you're responsible for 30
things,
but roughly speaking,
it's the same 30 things all the time and
roughly speaking,
they have to be taken care of the same
way each time.
So you have a finite domain of
responsibility and you can master it and
Iq will predict how fast you master it.
But once you master it will predict how
well you do.
What happens then in all likelihood is
that conscientiousness starts to predict
or maybe emotional stability starts to
predict or some of the other personality
factors start to become more important.
So but at 87 to 93,
you're down at the level of custodian
and janitor.
And then that's that and that's not so
good because you have the bottom 15 to
20 percent of the population who aren't
quite,
who haven't,
who don't have cognitive ability at that
level.
And so one of the things that you're
going to hear a lot about as you get
older is reasons for unemployment and
one of the prime reasons for
unemployment in the future is
increasingly going to be that there is
just nothing for someone of that level
of intelligence to do.
And this is partly why people hate icu
because you think that is a nasty,
nasty thing to conclude.
Let me tell you a story.
So I had a client at one point who,
I suspect he had a verbal Iq of about 85
and a nonverbal Iq that was lower.
Um,
he had other psychological issues,
but,
but we'll just concentrate on that one
for the time being.
And you know,
he had a hard time finding a job.
He was socially anxious and that didn't
help,
but you know,
even if he could overcome that,
it was very difficult for him to master
the basic skills that were involved in
what you would consider even relatively
straightforward tasks.
So I spent a lot of time trying to find
him a job,
which is,
was insanely difficult.
He went to the government first to get
help and they told him to,
you know,
type up his resume on a computer and
distributed.
It's like,
well,
that wasn't very helpful because he
didn't know how to use a computer and he
wasn't gonna type up his damn resume and
you know,
it was if you want to get a job,
go out and do the things that it would
take to get a job while yeah,
if you can do that then you don't have a
problem.
And so the government agencies were
completely useless,
you know,
and they were staffed by people who
would assume that if you didn't do what
you were advised to,
that you just didn't want to have a job
instead of ever thinking that maybe you
couldn't do it.
It's not that easy to use a computer.
So.
And then I tried to get him a volunteer
job.
Well you can bloody well forget about
that because it's harder to get a
volunteer job than it is to get a real
job.
And the reason for that is that you have
to step through a number of complex
bureaucratic hoops,
including having police check and you
know,
first of all,
that's intimidating as hell for people
even if they haven't done anything
wrong.
And second,
it's not that straightforward.
You know,
it involves maneuvering through a
complicated bureaucracy.
And that's not the only step.
There's all sorts of other steps.
So volunteer work,
that's out,
man,
that's,
that's just not gonna happen.
Not generally speaking.
And then I found him a job helping a guy
out.
You had a bicycle shop slash bookstore.
It was kind of a strange combination,
but it was a government subsidized
temporary position.
And then he did a good job at it.
He could,
he,
he was reshelving books and that sort of
thing.
And so he was reliable and he could do
that.
But you know,
the subsidy program ended in,
of course,
if you run a bike shop slash bookstore,
it's not like you have additional money
to hire someone because you know those
are.
That's a store that's just not going to
be generating maybe any income,
but certainly not enough to hire
someone.
So that fell apart.
Then I,
I did a bunch of con.
I did made a bunch of personal contacts
with charity organizations to see if I
can get them a volunteer position.
I finally got him a volunteer position,
so.
And then I went with him to train him at
the volunteer position and that was so
enlightening.
So what he had to do was he had a stack
of pieces of paper here and then a stack
of envelopes here.
And in principle the pieces of paper
which were letters were in the same
order as the envelopes work.
And so what he had to do was fold the
pieces of paper three times and stuff,
the folded piece of paper into the
envelope and then seal the envelope and
then put it here.
But it was a bit more complicated than
that because sometimes the letters were
French and sometimes they were in
English.
So what that meant was that he had to
watch and see that the French envelopes
went into this stack and the English and
envelopes went into that stock.
So that's one degree of complexity,
right?
But then it also turned out that those
damn envelopes had to be run through an
automatic letter sorting machine.
Now you might think,
well that doesn't matter,
but it does matter because those things
have very tightly defined tolerances.
And if you make a mistake,
imagine you fold the piece of paper and
the first time you fold it,
you made a mistake of an eighth of an
inch.
And then the next time you fold it,
you make another eighth of an inch
mistake.
That means your piece of papers now one
quarter inch out of true,
and then you stuff it in the envelope
and folded,
but you crinkled the envelope.
And so then the envelope gets stuck in
the automatic processing machines.
So I taught him probably 20 hours how to
fold this piece of paper into three and
he was a bit shaky and he just didn't
have the motor fine motor ability or the
cognitive ability to do that and then
I'll end with this.
When he finally couldn't do it anymore,
what happened was the letters came with
photographs attached to them and then he
had to fold the pieces of paper around
the photographs in a way that didn't
crumpled the photographs so that they
could still fit into the envelopes and
each photo was stapled maybe half an
inch different per piece of paper.
So then he had to fold them properly
with a different folding technique for
every piece of paper and he had to sort
them into French and English.
And then also if the envelopes and the
papers ever gone out of sync,
which they did now.
And then he had to figure out how to
sort the envelopes and the pieces of
paper to make sure that they were
matched with the proper.
You know,
they were matched with the proper
envelope.
It's like,
no,
that was the end of it.
And so I'll tell you the rest of his
story later.
So anyways,
you know,
there,
there is.
The moral of the story is if you're
smart,
you're privileged and thank God,
make use of it.
And if you're on the lower end of the
ICU distribution,
man,
you've got one tough life ahead of you,
has nothing to do with willingness to
work or virtually nothing.
And it's a good thing to know,
even though it's horrible.
Entrepreneurial reframing.